hi everyone my name is mohammad rovani
in this like uh i would like to tell you
about beating the folklore algorithm for
dying damage matching this is a joint
work with amy soberi and david white
from stanford university in the dynamic
matching problem we are given a graph g
that undergoing edge deletion and edge
insertions the goal is to maintain a
large matching after each
insertion and deletions
so
in this graph red it just shows the
maximum matching of the current graph
and after the green edge added to the
graph
we will we will change the matching to
the new
matching that is larger after the
edge insertion and so
we use mu mu of g in this stock to show
the size of the maximum matching of the
graph g
previous hardness results shows that
maintaining the exact
dynamic maximum matching
is not possible in sub linear time so we
are looking for approximate dynamic
matching algorithm
there are two main properties that
that are important when we are talking
about approximate dynamic matching
algorithm one of them is the update time
which means the total time that the
algorithm is spent after uh each in edge
insertion and deletions to maintain the
matching
and also
the approximation factor which shows the
ratio between the
matching that the algorithm maintained
and the maximum matching of the graph
dynamic maximum matching has been
extensively
studied during the last years
there are numerous works that
works on different trade-offs to get
different trade-offs for
running time and also approximation
ratio
also there are some
conditional hardness results for
maintaining
exact dynamic matching
maximum matching
but before going to the details of our
algorithm and also talking about
previous
results about the dynamic matching let's
look at
a simple folklore algorithm
that is not worthy to publish anywhere
so in the folklore algorithm if an hd
inserted to the graph and both of
endpoints of e are
are unmatched
then we add the hp to the
matching that we maintain otherwise we
do not add
the key to the matching
also if an hd deleted from the graph
it's if it's not in the matching we just
ignore it and otherwise if it's in the
in the matching that we maintained we
delete the edge and look
over all its neighbors to see if there
exists the neighbor w that
it doesn't have any
matching edges so we can add this new
edge to the matching that we maintain
so for example if this
red edge deleted from the graph and it
was in the maximum matching then we look
over the neighbors of v to see if there
exists a neighbor w that doesn't have
any
uh matching edge and in this case we add
the hbw to the
like maximum to the matching that we
maintain
the update time of this algorithm is
order of n because after
each edge insert after each edge
deletion we are looking
over all the neighbors of the deleted
edge
so
in the worst case it takes uh order of n
to
iterate over the neighbors of b
also the matching that the algorithm
maintains is a maximal matching which is
a two approximation
but despite the various works that has
been done
on this uh on the dynamic matching
problem still this folklore algorithm is
unbeaten until this year which means
that there is no deterministic
algorithm with approximation ratio less
than two
which runs in sublinear worst case
update type
our main result is that there exists a
deterministic slightly better than two
approximation algorithm for dynamic
matching problem with worst case update
time off and two three quarter
there are there are two follow-up works
uh by
keys
which appears in the ipccs
2020 and also by one by grand during at
all which appeared
on sosa 2020 when both of these works
improved our bounds on this problem but
the techniques are completely different
for for this paper and the other two
there are some prior algorithms that
beat the folklore algorithm
with having some structural assumption
on the input graph for example if the
graph has a bounded degree then there
exists an algorithm by kubton thing
which is a deterministic one plus
approximation in worst case update time
of of delta where delta is the maximum
degree of the
graph
so assume that we have a
subgraph that has a small degree which
contains a large matching we call this
subgraph
as a sparsifier
so how how we can use this bounded
degree
algorithm by group damping there's a
general framework that's maintained as
sparsifier that sparse square is a
which has a small degree but has a large
matching of the graph and then applied
the above results on the sparsifier to
er to get the terminus to get a
large matching in the lower end time
also by assuming that the input graph is
bipartite the existing algorithm by
bernie stein and stein in 2015
uh which maintains a trip half
approximation uh
dynamic matching algorithm
deterministically in update time of
route and
uh how we can use this
uh results uh this is our the
contribution of our paper that we show
how we can
reduce the
general dynamic matching to the
bipartite dynamic matching and use the
results of the
results for the bipartite graphs
in the rest of the type
first we will
talk about the kernels which is the
two plus epsilon approximate sparsifier
is the main
starting port point of our algorithm
then we will see how we can augment the
kernel to
breaking the barrier of two
and also at the end we will put
everything together to beat the folklore
algorithm
the starting point of our algorithm is a
kernel kernel is a
sparsifier that was inter that's first
introduced by bhattacharya henzinger
italiano in 2018 and has been used in
several wars after that
uh kernel
an epsilon d kernel of a graph g is a
sub graph k that's uh
that has two properties the first one is
that the maximum degree of the kernel of
the subgraph
so k is
at most d and also for each edge that
doesn't appear in the
kernel at least one of its end point has
a degree greater than or equal d times
one minus epsilon so in other words uh
the maximum degree of the subgraph is d
and
each edge that doesn't appear in the end
point has one end point that
has a degree roughly equal to d
so
uh in this c in this graph the kdd shows
a complete bipartite graph of
each part has a d note
and note uh so
uh k kdd is a kernel for this graph
because the maximum degree of the graph
is at most some graph is almost d and
also for each black is that doesn't
appear in the kernel
one of its endpoint has a degree equal
to d
[Music]
we have a kernel demo that shows that
the size of the maximum matching of the
kernel
is at least two plus epsilon
approximation of the maximum matching of
the
original graph g
so
so how we can use the kernel
to
get a dynamic matching algorithm
and as a reminder there existed
deterministic one plus epsilon
approximation in worst case update time
of delta
uh by gupta and pink for the bounded
degree graphs so we can in order to get
two plus epsilon approximation we can
combine kernels with the above algorithm
so
assume that t is the time to maintain a
kernel
and also let c be the number of the
changes to the kernel player update this
is an important parameter because each
time that we changes the kernel
we have to apply the above
results on top of that to maintain a
matching so that
so the number of the changes to the
kernel is important
and also let d be the
in maximum degree of the subgraph or in
other words the parameter that you use
for the kernel
then
by using this framework the
update time will be t plus c times d
where c times the
appears because
because of applying gs the above
algorithms c times
on this
in this framework
the bad news is that
all the prior deterministic algorithms
that maintain kernel
uh has
had
c times d equal to omega of n which
means that if we are looking for subnear
algorithm we don't have any prior
results that we can use as a sovereignty
so
our
secondary results uh
shows that there exists a deterministic
epsilon d kernel algorithm in worst case
update time of n over d and also it only
changes the kernel once per update
so in other words the c in our algorithm
is equal to
one
so by choosing the appropriate d we can
have a sub-linear
algorithm for maintaining the kernel the
deterministic
worst case update type
so let's see how we can break the
barrier of two
it currently contains um matching that
is better than two minus epsilon
approximation of g then
by applying the gupta ampang result we
we can have a better than two minus
epsilon approximation algorithm
so we are in a good shape in this case
so for the rest of the type we assume
that the size of the maximum matching of
g is greater than or equal to minus
epsilon times mu of g or in other words
we are in the tight case of the kernel
where the matching of the candle is not
good enough for us to apply the group
dumping result directly
we proved that
kernel contains a merely maximal
matching or in other words
if it removes fewer pieces from the
graph then the
m is the maximum matching of the graph
so in this example the red edges inside
the kernel shows a maximal matching of
the graph
an augmenting pass is alternating past
that it starts from and ends on
unmatched vertices
so in other words the path that the
first vertex and the last vertex is
uh unmatched vertices and the edges
alternate between non-matching and
matching edges
if you have an augmenting path then we
can flip the edges of the augmenting
parts together to get a larger matching
previous results shows that the nearly
maximal matching must contain many short
augmented passes so in this example
these green boxes all all are the
uh left three augmenting passes
so our general idea
is to characterize the tight case of the
kernel when the size of the matching is
not good enough it's not large enough
and then we augment the general k with
length three augmenting passes with
respect to nearly maximum matching
so in this example if
if we augment the kernel with green
boxes then we have this new
matching which is larger
recall from the uh recall the statement
of the kernel lemma that
an absolute d channel of g
and has a matching that is better than
two plus epsilon approximation
so in other words mu of g is less than
or equal to plus epsilon times mu of k
first we need to unbox the kernel lemma
in order to characterize the type case
of the kernel
the proof overview
uh has two estates
uh first we show that k contains a large
fractional matching
and after that we show that there exists
an integral matching in cave it's
roughly
equal so we do not
lose a lot
when we move from the fractional
matching to integral matching
for the proof assume that we fix a
maximum matching m star
we
we consider a fraction on matching x um
with such that
if we assume that the
yb be the sum of the
fractional values of the h incident to b
then
we claim that the sum of the yv is
greater than or equal to
one minus epsilon for for an ht
uh if if if you disclaim uh
and this sum over the
values of the maximum matching ms start
because the ends points are disjoint
then we have that the sum of the
fractional values are greater than or
equal half of the one minus epsilon
times mu of g
so
if if graph g is bypass that the proof
is complete because
the fraction of matching poly top is
integral for the bipartite graphs then
we have the same results for the
integral matching on this case
otherwise if g is not bipartite we can
use the division theorem to show that we
do not lose a lot and
when we move from the
fractional matching two integral
matching in this
example
we extend the kernel lemma to a newer
version
we show that
at most epsilon mu
k edges in msr satisfy either of the
following conditions
first the sum of the
degree of the endpoint of e
is greater than or equal to d times one
plus epsilon in other words for a
matching edge the sum of its degree
in the kernel cannot be much much larger
than
d and also for those edges that are also
inside the kernel we have that the sum
of their degrees cannot be less than or
equal to d times 1 minus epsilon in
other words it cannot be much lower than
d
the proof is
similar to the proof of the kernel let
me recall that
we define a fractional
um matching such that the sum of the
the sum of the fractional values of the
matching edges was greater than or equal
to one uh half of the one minus epsilon
times mu of g essentially the same proof
shows that the sum of the
yb for
for fixed hd is greater than or equal
one plus epsilon before that we have we
have this claim that it was
greater than or equal one minus epsilon
but now it's greater than or equal one
plus epsilon for all edges inside the
maximum matching that satisfy one of the
conditions of one or two
so if we have many edges that satisfy
either of these two conditions then you
have a better approximation ratio
but how we can find missing edges of the
augmenting classes
we define a node's
classification that has three different
classes
a high degree node is a node that has
degree greater than or equal to d times
one minus epsilon a low degree node is a
vertex that has a degree less than or
equal t times
epsilon and all other nodes are medium
nodes
we have the following observation that
at most epsilon times mu k of edges or
in other words very few edges in the
maximum matching that is what either of
the following conditions the first
condition is that
the end point of the
the matching edge can be high and high
or high in medium the second is that if
the
if the edge is inside the kernel
its endpoint can be low and low or low
and medium
this observation
results by the extended kernel lemma
because of the
constraint on the degree of the classes
so
by this observation uh we have uh we
have
um a few types of the length three
augmenting passes that all that most of
the electric organizations belong to one
of these types
as you can see in the picture most of
these types
has low degree notes at their endpoints
and the dash edges which are the missing
edges are
between the high degree nose and low
degree notes so
intuitively if we are looking for
finding the missing edges we we need to
find the bipartite matching between the
height degree note and low degree notes
this is the place that the
bipartite matching algorithm plays a
role in our algorithm let mh be the
three half plus epsilon approximation
algorithm
by bearing stain and
stein for the bipartite graph and also
let
a of mh be the minimum number of the
disjoint length through augmenting
passes results by
a union of the kernel and a bipartite
matching between high degree notes and
low degree notes
then we have the following lemma that's
the number of the
disjoint length three augmenting passes
will be greater than or equal
to epsilon times mu of g
so if we can find
a maximum if we can maintain a matching
between high degree nodes and low degree
nodes then we can find
[Music]
a fraction of length three augmenting
passes
so let's have a recap about how we can
augment the kernel
we maintain the kernel with view changes
per update
if the kernel is not better than two
minus epsilon approximation then we can
find that to
find the fraction of augmenting passes
to add to the kernel in order to make it
better than two minus epsilon
approximation we maintain a three half
plus epsilon approximate matching
between high degree nodes and low degree
nodes by fairness stain and stein
algorithm
but note that the degree can change
abruptly a node can move from a high
high class to medium class or from low
class to medium class
quickly
in order to
relax this problem we use
an approach degree
for each vertex to maintain
uh
maintain the bipartisan matching between
high degree and low degree nodes
then we can bound the number of the
changes to the bipartite matching
and at the end we have that the size of
the
matching of the original graph is less
than or equal to minus epsilon times the
maximum matching of the kernel uni and
the bipartite matching between high high
notes and low notes
let's put everything together to beat
the folklore algorithm
so we maintain the kernel with uh order
of and over the algorithm
and
one change to the kernel this change of
the carrier can cause order of n over d
changes to the bipartite
and matching between the bipartisan
subgraph between high degree nodes and
low degree notes
if we use approximate degree for
degree classification
maintaining a bipartite matching takes
root n
and also it causes order of one changes
to the matching
also by the result of the group time
plane uh
we know that the bounded degree matching
algorithm takes order of the update time
if the maximum degree of the subgraph is
d
so if
if we sum all all this time together and
choose d to be equal to
n to three quarter then we have our
order of n to three quarter running time
also
we proved that the union of the kernel
and the
bipartite matching between high degree
nodes and low degree nodes is a two
minus epsilon uh sparsifier for the
original graph so if we apply the gupta
peng result on
top of this as part of specifier then we
have a two minus set of epsilon
approximation algorithm for dynamic
matching
so our main result
uh is that there exists a deterministic
slightly better than two approximation
dynamic matching algorithm with worst
case update time of n
into three quarter
there are several interesting questions
and what is that what's the best
approximation ratio that one can get in
sub linear time
currently it's three half plus epsilon
which is by the work of bernstein and
stein in 2016.
another interesting question is that
can we get two minus some constant
approximation or can we be two in poly
logarithmic update time
and the last question is that
uh what is the fastest one plus epsilon
approximation currently is a root order
of root m which is uh
which is by uh gupta and bank in 2013.
thank you very much for your listening